I love fire I don't agree very so much  very relaxing yeah you doing good yeah  I've only been here for a day but I'm  just like flabbergasted because this is  it's just that it's just it's very  unfortunate for me  I don't know why I have bad luck I'll  get really excited about something and  something will like almost be there and  then it doesn't happen or it gets taken  away from me I have no idea why it's  happening to me just it's been like that  for a while like years which is it it's  just disappointing  I just want for one's it to just go well  I was so excited to come here and I was  so excited about potential and just free  all this happened in one day it's like  oh it's overwhelming  you